unsupervised learning and
semi-supervised learning inside of
tensorflow which all of you might know
about uh it's a python deep learning
framework so just a little bit about
myself uh before we get started i'm
currently in grade 11. i'm at gonzaga
secondary but i also study at athabasca
university where i'm learning a little
bit about c plus plus and calculus
i also founded a hackathon called
ignition hacks which introduced youth to
ai and machine learning and once again i
also placed finalists at hack the north
2021 uh producing basically a speech
therapy application called viva which
ran on deep learning google cloud and a
variety of other web frameworks that we
made throughout that weekend
so
just in terms of what i wanted to
discuss today uh it's mostly focused on
unsupervised learning but we wanted to
get a start with uh just the landscape
of learning in general so focusing on
something that's a little bit more
familiar uh specifically supervised
learning and then diving right into
unsupervised learning with uh
basically k-means and also uh performing
classification using the k-nearest
neighbor algorithm then i want to dive
into a little bit about again so
generative adversarial networks and
basically produce a few uh custom-made
digits using uh deep learning and
general adversarial networks in
tensorflow and finally i wanted to
discuss a little bit about uh tensorflow
with basically semi-supervised learning
and its applications in competition such
as
kaggle and kind of noisy student
learning and basically just pseudo
labeling in general so let's dive right
into it so in terms of just supervised
learning
i'm pretty sure a lot of us are a little
bit familiar about the ideas of
supervised learning but basically
oftentimes you'll have a
very small amount of xy pairs so for
instance that might be images to classes
or maybe text to classes and stuff like
that and you'll just go ahead and run
your deep learning model
trying to figure out some given function
that will map from your x to your y
now in reality there's going to be a lot
more data that is unsupervised just your
x data that you can probably web scrape
and you can probably grab even just 3
000 images right off the web right away
in like two seconds
now labeling data is a little bit harder
because we need to pay somebody or we
need to get some other a method of
converting those x's into y's and that's
obviously not using deep learning that
would be through a human in the loop and
so massive companies would pay
thousands or basically just a lot of
money and time just to actually have
people hand label all of that data and
so in the end you'll have less data in
total but you have some data set that
maps from x to y and that is considered
your supervised learning data set
now after you've trained your model
you actually have a few options with it
and so specifically for just supervised
learners you'll stop right there and you
might deploy your model and sometimes
you'll find some internal bias and stuff
like that but for people who know a
little bit more about unsupervised
learning you might extend your model to
get more performance using a technique
called pseudo-labeling and that's where
we dive into the realm of super
semi-supervised learning and so that's
where you take all of your web scrape
data so you might run some algorithm to
grab all the images off of like google
images or some other other like massive
public data set just has all the images
and like that's been uploaded to the web
or something and you might go ahead and
actually run your trained model to
classify all those other images and so
you might just retrain your model on
your massive data set now and get a
model that works a lot better and so
that's kind of a massive kaggle
technique that's used to boost
performance by maybe a few percent but
ultimately can end up winning
competitions so i know from personal
experience i participated in the kaggle
hub map challenge and was able to place
29th in the world uh just by using
pseudo-labeling so i actually leveraged
some of the kidneys and went ahead and
actually um ran my
basically it was a segmentation model to
grab more data and in total basically
improve my model i think was by three
percent which ended up boosting my
position from 100th to 29th so just the
power of pseudo labeling it really just
allows you to push your model even
further
now before i dive into a little bit
about semi-supervised learning um let's
just quickly cover the ideas of
unsupervised cluster learning so
i'm pretty sure that
just like what i've been talking about a
little bit before but labels in general
are pretty expensive so you might have
to be a massive company to go ahead and
label all the data that you have so for
instance you can go ahead and web scrape
all the data off the internet but to
actually go ahead and write down your
data and map from x to y that requires a
lot of human workers and it's not only
laborious but it's also going to take a
lot of time and sometimes and this is
one of the more
major applications of unsupervised
learning your data is very very
basically time sensitive you need that
data trained and used and applied to
your model right away you don't really
have time for human workers to go ahead
and label each of your examples before
you can retrain your model you just have
to go ahead and apply it and so this is
where unsupervised learning comes in
where you don't have to have that human
loop you can just go ahead and train
your model on the x data pairs and so
specifically in this case sorry my
computer's lagging a little bit because
i think it's from zoom but um i'm pretty
sure most of us have seen a few
applications of unsupervised learning so
for instance the classics are
dimensionality reduction so for instance
you might go ahead and reduce the
dimension of an image down to something
that's a little bit more compressed so
there's a few algorithms that do that so
for instance like the jpeg compression
algorithm but sometimes you can actually
go ahead and use deep learning to go
ahead and compress all your images down
to even something as small as 10 bytes
just basically a vector or i guess it
would be 40 bytes but you'd press it
down into 10 numbers and then from that
your model would learn some embedding
space that it could use and recreate
that image again and we'll actually see
that using something called an auto
encoder
another example of deep learning for
unsupervised learning is the idea of
clustering so if you are a business
person in theory you could actually go
ahead and segment out your customers
using unsupervised learning and based on
what other customers in that same
cluster have basically been like
researching and what they seem to have
purchased you can go ahead and recommend
people similar products which tends to
actually work out very very well and
amazon uses that technique
now in terms of clustering just diving a
little bit deeper into that i'm pretty
sure most of us have seen the idea of k
n which is k nearest neighbors but just
to be clear and have everybody on be on
the same page the k nearest neighbor
algorithm is a form of basically
clustering data and so
honestly it's purely mathematical and
the idea is to start off with random
centroids
so you might say that oh my data might
have five groups and so you'd plot down
your x centroids and just random
locations to start now this is where the
machine learning comes in
basically you would from every single
other data point inside of your x pair
you would then go ahead and map that to
the clearest to the nearest centroid and
so you'd say okay i'm going to go ahead
and re-cluster my data and so in this
case you might end up with three red
dots and four blue dots like six the
green dots or something like that now
the issue is that your initial centroids
will not be perfect and that's the
basics of machine learning in general
your starting position will never be
good so how can we go ahead and actually
improve that we recompute our centroids
by finding the middle point inside of
all of our unsupervised data and so in
this case you would go ahead and compute
a new centroid which is step three
and by repeating that process like
iteratively just continuing to create
new centroids essentially clustering and
basically going to the middle again you
can actually create nearly perfect
centroids most of the time now obviously
this depends on your initialization but
that's kind of the basics of
unsupervised learning or in this case
would be k n algorithm
so
some things that people haven't really
seen before
is
actually we can actually apply the k n
algorithm to do classification and so it
sounds crazy to begin with and my
diagram isn't exactly perfect i made
that through one of the neural network
generator for like papers and it's not
exactly used for k n so it doesn't look
perfect but the idea is is that we can
actually use deep learning plus our
regular canon algorithm to go ahead and
classify images in this case i'll use
mnist as our example
using k-nearest neighbors and so how we
go ahead and do this is we would start
with an autoencoder and using this
autoencoder we can actually
create an embedding space for each of
our images so for instance the number
nine might get mapped down into a little
bit more of a longer embedding that
essentially you would start off with
your 28 by 20 image which is what
eminence gives you to begin with you
would then go ahead and down convolute
it so basically just use a regular
convolutional neural network and you'll
map that down to your embedding space
and so in my case i use an embedding
space of 100 just so we could capture
enough data
and then you would essentially train it
to begin with with the task of auto
encoding which is the idea to take an
image or some sort of data compress it
down
and then essentially expand it back to
the original form and through doing that
and iteratively improving your deep
learning model let's just say through a
convolutional neural network or even
just a dense autoencoder both would work
for mnist this is an example but
basically through trying to improve it
slowly by making sure that your end
result is equal to your initial
beginning image you're essentially going
to learn in that middle spot where
you've compressed all of your embeddings
down into one space you're going to
learn an embedding that's going to be
pretty good so for instance number nine
might point in one direction while the
number eight will point into another now
the importance is that if you write the
number eight in a different way and
ideally your neural network will be able
to point in a vector that is in the same
direction because it's able to
understand what kind of site what kind
of signs inside the image the number
eight represents and so through
compressing all of our images in the
amiss data set into that embedding space
we've captured some important
information through just simple
unsupervised learning so that's our
dimensionality reduction already in
action we've taken an autoencoder just
taken the x values and we've learned
some information about it now let's go
ahead and extend that even further and
pop on a canon classifier where we can
go ahead and learn that embedding space
that the auto encoder has created and so
in that case you would pop on your canon
classifier say i have 10 nodes because
there's 10 in there's 10 digits that we
can learn and then basically have the k
n algorithm run
and find the centroids and so through
doing that now let's say you have a new
image and you've trained the entire
system now two unsupervised models
combined together you can go ahead and
run your images through and you can
actually get a classification results
now obviously it's not going to pop out
the number nine or something like that
from your images because it doesn't even
know what the y label is but the number
nine no matter how it's written if
you've trained an ideal model it will
end up in the same cluster effectively
performing classification using
unsupervised learning and so in this
case our metric unlike the regular
accuracy you do something called
normalized mutual information which is
basically where you can map your regular
labels that you would have had for
testing to whatever class cluster labels
you've created with your unsupervised
model and essentially it is similar to
accuracy it will give you a value from
zero to one depending on how close those
clusters are
and so our goal is basically to
calculate how close our clusters are to
the true labels
now i've popped into the chat uh when i
started essentially a few co-lab
notebooks uh unfortunately due to the
time i won't be able to run through them
all so i just have a few images of what
the results will be and so on your own
time if you're interested you guys can
actually go ahead and run them and
you'll get similar results but
effectively that would be my first
system on the on the left you'll see my
first auto encoder where i've
effectively taken our mnist data sets
and my i am this images and i have um
effectively compress them down into some
embedding space and you can see the
recreated image is a little bit more
blurry
but it ultimately captures the value of
what what it means to be the number two
and so when you run it through the auto
encoder you will get something similar
back and now i've popped on in the image
on the top right essentially a new
k-means classifier and so it clusters
into 10 and then it makes predictions
and from my original just simple k k n
algorithm that i ran it actually had
huge improvements compared to the other
just because of how it's able to
capitalize on the embedding space
so
now that i've dived a little bit into
the canon algorithm
let's go ahead and dive into gans so
gans or general adversarial networks is
another powerful unsupervised technique
used to essentially create new images
and create new data to improve your
models further now why would we even use
gans i'll skip that slide and come back
but in general for things like kaggle
sometimes you won't even have the data
sometimes it's proprietary and so you
can't just go ahead and web scrape for
millions of images sometimes you only
have certain types of images that you
can learn on and so if it's especially
if it's proprietary data it's going to
be very very difficult
so sometimes you won't actually have
that kind of data to begin with you will
have proprietary data that like let's
just say it's not publicly on the
internet and so gans provide us with a
very very powerful method to create new
images and create new data to train on
and so for instance you might create a
new larger test data set to then go
ahead and suit a label which i'll dive
into at the very end and so
now that we've addressed why we might
actually use again what even is a gan or
a general adversarial network basically
you're having a fight between two neural
networks you have a generator who is the
artist basically the generator will be
creating a new image similar to an auto
encoder it will start off with some
random noise and create an image out of
it let's just say it's a cat and so
through training and fighting with this
discriminator which is the art critic
saying is this image real or not you can
take some sample of data that you
already have and the data that the gan
or the generator has created and
ultimately the generator's goal is to be
able to fool the discriminator to create
some sort of image that the
discriminator cannot even tell that is
fake data
and so the discriminator's job at this
point is to be able to differentiate
between between the two and so at this
point you're solving two optimization
problems the generator is trying to fool
the discriminator
and the discriminator is trying to get
it accurate and so
for that reason um gans are typically
considered what's called unstable
because sometimes basically nothing will
learn because the discriminator and the
generator have settled in but if you're
able to train with a very very effective
model which is why uh typical gans
networks exist like big gan or like
different kinds of gans like uh dc gan
and stuff like that there's a whole
bunch of algorithms and models that
exist but um basically you have to
construct one that's nearly perfect
because when those two neural networks
are basically battling each other trying
to figure out um the discriminator
trying to figure out if images are real
or not and the generator trying to
create new imagers that look real
essentially sometimes you'll end up
collapsing and that's called gan mode
collapse and so ultimately we're trying
to create a model that will train and
generate new images without collapsing
so
you might ask
normally i'm used to solving one
optimization problem just how can i get
from x to y but with gans we actually
have two because the generator is trying
to create new images and that's a
separate optimization problem and the
discriminator is trying to do the
classic task of just classifying it and
so we actually go ahead and create two
loss functions and optimize on two
different things and so how we go ahead
and do this is that the generator has a
loss function that essentially is split
in two number one
uh basically that actually i think i
flip that around by accident but um the
discriminator has the job of classifying
between the real and the fake images
this is your classic classification
algorithm so i think i mixed these up by
accident but i'll fix those slides after
but um in general it's trying to figure
out which one's real and which one's not
and so that might be through just binary
cross-entropy just the standard loss
function where the real one should be
classified as one and the fake one
should be classified as zero now the gan
or the sorry the generator should be
trying to fool the discriminator and
there's only one real metric and it's
how accurate was the discriminator to
begin with and so
basically
if
the fake images so in this case y fake
was classified as one the generator will
suffer no loss because that's what it
was supposed to do and so basically the
generator is trying to optimize on how
much the discriminator was failing and
so by creating two optimizers in
tensorflow in this case you would go
ahead and optimize on both so you'd use
apply gradients but you'd have two
optimizers one optimizing the generator
and one optimizing the discriminator
now in terms of the notebook again
that's in the chat so you guys can go
ahead and run that
i'll have some images of two you'll see
that as my generator and discriminator
are slowly training we start off with
this kind of random images so this is
after i trained once that's epoch 1.
effectively you'll see that it's kind of
random noise these aren't really numbers
you can kind of see rough shapes but by
the end when i'm trained by i think it
was 50 epochs i didn't train it for too
too long but you'll see that they're
actually recognizable to a human that
one's the number nine six two eight four
three three two the images aren't
obviously perfect because i just took a
simple dense model so you'll see that
there's a convolution and then there's
just a few dense layers but it's able to
generally learn what it means to be a
number and the generator is able to
somewhat fool the discriminator now
you'll see that i've actually created
two different optimizers inside of the
top left image or top right image
basically there is one that is going to
be
the basically the discriminators
gradients and the discriminators
optimizer and there's another one that
says generators optimizer and the
generator the generator's gradients and
so unlike custom loops that you might be
doing with tensorflow before um you're
actually going to have to create two
gradient tapes because both of them will
be creating gradients for the separate
optimization task and they'll both be
training at once and so you can kind of
see how it's a little bit unstable but
one thing that you definitely want to
see while you're printing out your
losses while you're testing and
debugging your neural network is that
you actually don't want to see either of
the losses go down to zero because that
means one of your models have collapsed
and
basically one over the other for
instance if your discriminator has
achieved zero loss that basically means
that at this point your generator has
given up because your generator at this
point cannot create images that have
fooled the discriminator and the
discriminator is perfect every single
time so it has nowhere to learn and the
generator is kind of just struggling
what you want to see is that they're
both kind of fluctuating but in general
they're both going down a little bit
so
effectively you're trying to make sure
that they're both training at the same
time and the only real way to test
whether or not your gan is truly
learning
is basically by testing by seeing the
images themselves which is why gans are
so particularly hard to train because
you can't just simply use something as
simple as like maybe just loss functions
and so in this case
you can see that i basically trained it
by looking at the images but for more
complicated tasks you'll actually have
to test more often just to make sure
that at one point you can tell which
epochs it collapsed and how can i adjust
the model to reflect and basically
improve my model after my gan collapsed
and so that's definitely a technique
that i'd be happy to discuss on slack on
just different techniques to make sure
that my gan doesn't collapse but in
general using stuff like washer steam
loss uh i didn't use it in this case i
just used a simple uh least squares loss
but there's a variety of different gan
losses that will improve stability in
order to improve your gans performance
and so you'll see that state-of-the-art
gans use incredibly complex models and
incredibly complex loss functions just
because they're simulating such large
images at this point i think some of
them can produce three thousand by three
thousand pixel images without collapsing
which is absolutely amazing
so now with the last few minutes i think
i have eight minutes left uh is the idea
of semi-supervised learning and so this
is one of those things if you guys are
caglers
is one of the most important concepts
that you need to know if your goal is to
win
so in general if you just use the train
data most people know how to do that
most people on your kaggle platform your
kaggle competition will already know how
to apply a basic model to train a neural
network and achieve very decent
performance so for instance you might go
on to like in this case i'll use the
kaggle hub map challenge because i
participated in it but you might train
just a very simple a segmentation model
like u-net or something like that using
like an efficient backbone or something
you might just train a very very simple
cnn that runs for segmentation and
you'll train it on the x kidneys that
you have
now
most people already know how to do that
and will be able to achieve the results
that you've already gotten now how can i
go above and beyond and improve and
actually place and this is where semi
supervised learning and effectively
using pseudo labels comes in so there's
a few different semi-supervised learning
techniques and so number one you have
something called pseudo-labeling and
that's almost one of the most important
ones now another really relevant one
that has come in recently with uh
something called efficient and efficient
and v2 is the idea of noisy student
training and i'll dive into that first
now for very special applications
there's also something called
consistency training
that's basically where you want to make
sure that your model doesn't really have
too too much bias meaning that it's able
to actually work with um a variety of
different data whether it's augmented
whether it's reflected and stuff like
that it's able to basically work with
all the data augmentations and it
doesn't have to too much bias and so
i'll quickly explain that it's called
the two model or like the ii model
effectively you would train a model and
after you're doing that you're going to
train with a regular uh regularization
loss so for instance for one of your x
pairs you're going to pass in an
augmentation that might reflect the
image and the other one might rotate the
image by 90 degrees now in general a
good cnn depending on the application
should be able to classify both as the
same thing now to ensure regularization
you'll actually stop it right there you
won't take the class labels you'll take
the embeddings and you'll go ahead and
compute a least squares or something
like that to make sure that they
actually get the same embedding meaning
they've seen the same thing out of that
image and so
that just basically helps out in terms
of making sure that your your model is
completely the same and can do the same
thing even when it's augmented data so
that's important for kaggles and has
been used in previous kaggles to win
competitions just to make sure that your
private data so something that might be
a little bit different than your public
data your model will still perform
equally as well
now something that's become really
really relevant is the idea of
pseudo-labeling and so pseudo labeling
has always been kind of an amazing
technique and it has actually won a
variety of different competitions in
kaggle and other applications and so
your standard classic example is the
santander customer transaction challenge
where pseudo labeling was the number one
factor that boosted the number one
winner by zero point zero zero zero five
percent accuracy and they managed to
pull away with twenty five thousand
dollars from that kaggle challenge now
other ones that have also won with
pseudo-labeling include like the tgs
salt segmentation challenge global wheat
object detection and stuff like that but
um ultimately pseudo labeling is almost
essential to apply when you're taggling
or even working with real world data to
make sure that your models
work
work the absolute best that they can
and so uh yes david i will post my
slides i'll probably post it uh in the
chat if i have time and if not i'll post
it inside of the talks channel inside of
the slack
um
in terms of how pseudo labeling actually
can work there's three main techniques
that you might use and i've actually
drawn them with an arrow to show which
one's typically the best now your
classic example that most people
actually know how to do
is the idea of
the classic example is the idea to
basically train your model supervised
and then go ahead and
amass your pseudo label so just predict
on the test data whatever you have
access to maybe you've scraped it
combine the two data sets and train
again but train the exact same model and
just fine tune it on the pseudo labels
now as although this is the simplest you
can do it in one shot
this technique typically performs the
worst out of all of them now the classic
technique that most people do is the
idea of training and restarting again
before training on your pseudo labels so
you might train a preliminary model go
ahead and suit a label and then combine
your two data sets refresh your model
from imagenet weights or whatever you
started with and train it all on the
entire data set again and so by doing
that your model can actually learn a
little bit more than perhaps just fine
tuning we're just learning a little bit
because your learning rate at that point
is so small
now
something that's a little bit more
powerful and it should be used very
situationally is entirely pre-training
on pseudo labels you might go ahead and
train your models on the supervised data
predict your pseudo labels and then go
ahead and pre-train your model so you'd
start completely from random
initialization maybe from xavier
initialization or gloria but you would
just start completely from scratch and
then you instead of starting from
something like imagenet which has
already been trained and you have like
your pre-trained weights and you're just
transfer learning you'll actually
transfer learn on your pseudo labels
which have a lot more data uh hopefully
your ex data should have a lot more data
than your sorry your unsupervised data
that you had to suit a label it should
be a lot more and so you'll pre-train
all of that pseudo data
and then go ahead and train again and
you'll fine-tune on your supervised data
which should be the most accurate and so
that technique can actually work the
best and has won many kaggle
competitions but it should be used very
very situationally
now just a few tips and tricks before
you guys go ahead and actually go ahead
and apply pseudo-labeling into your real
world like applications um make sure
that your pseudo labels actually
represent the actual data set um pseudo
labels can sometimes not be as
representative as you might expect and
so if you end up training and
pseudo-training is a classic term on
data that doesn't actually represent
just like anything like even with
supervised learning your model won't do
well and you'll actually lose
performance
furthermore if you ever have the
opportunity to use soft pseudo labels
meaning rather than having like let's
say your model predicts 0.9 instead of
the hard one
use those because it typically teaches
the model more because you'll be able to
figure out which models confuse the
teacher compared to which models have
just been confidently thresholded so
soft super labels typically work a lot
better but um they're situational once
again because it's sometimes tough to
integrate that into your training
pipeline and furthermore uh sometimes
you might need multiple rounds of
pseudo-labeling you might need to train
the model create another one and retrain
it and then do it again and so sometimes
you might train three or four times and
slowly see diminishing results but still
improving results on your private data
set and so it's kind of just an ability
to do multiple rounds of pseudo-labeling
now my only concern with that and again
it should be used situationally is
because you might overfit on the pseudo
data set and so make sure not like you
might overfit on some of your data just
because you're retraining on the same
data set again and again and again and
your errors might get propagated if you
do it a little bit incorrectly so again
um mates like sometimes errors might get
propagated throughout the networks and
so it's again situational
now the last thing i want to cover
because i'm running out of time is the
idea of noisy students and so noisy
student training is something that was
applied to efficient net inefficient mv2
and it's another super semi supervised
technique where they basically train a
simple teacher model that then learns
your pseudo labels and then you'll train
an even larger student so the student
will be technically supposed to be
smarter than the teacher
now this is pretty classic to train
again but to use an entirely new model
and apply a bunch of noise to the data
basically the student was able to learn
a lot more general features achieving a
lot better results and state-of-the-art
results at the time
so with that
thanks pi data for the opportunity to
speak today uh if you have any other
questions i think i'm not sure if i have
any other time but uh feel free to leave
it in slack and be happy to answer
thanks so much
you